The joe rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code named Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
That's right.
It's you beat off into it.
Brendan Walsh is scared of it.
I offered it.
Think about it.
It was like,
oh man.
Well,
I might not be within my best interest to introduce to my life.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't need to get any more in the like fucking jerk and off than I am already.
Like,
it's like,
it's a fucking waste of time.
You know what's funny too?
I had a dream last night that like I had a dream about like I was going to get a
fleshlight like I had decided I was ready to do it.
Yeah.
And you just called me today about this,
that you're going to buy it.
Well,
it was like I want it to fuck a rubber pussy and I dream like it was just a
weird dream and like just specifically this dream about a sex toy.
Yeah.
I mean it wasn't about like,
yeah,
my friend was in it and he had like this fucking thing like that was like
sucking his dick.
That looked pretty complicated.
I don't know man.
It's a weird dream.
It was pretty complicated.
Like a mechanical thing?
Yeah,
like it was a two part.
Like it had like a almost like a little gas tank,
you know like that you would use for like helium balloons.
Like it was a fucking weird contract.
Did you eat before you went to bed before you had this dream?
I Hate Pink Berry last night.
Was that you think that was a,
I don't know who would really give you a weird dream did you put on there?
I put Mochi.
I mean I usually don't eat late at night and I never like last time I pink was
probably like four months ago,
maybe more.
We know that certain
compounds in food definitely affect like Melatonin definitely affects the way
you dream,
you know,
and yeah.
A lot of people say these Alpha brain pills and we've been saying they
definitely affected.
We've just been hearing about that.
Took tressel told him,
I'll give you a bottle.
Tell me what you're thinking.
They suck.
Please tell me.
No I don't.
I don't want to believe it's just a placebo effect.
I don't want to believe it.
Just we'll see about that because of the dreams,
the dreams that the number one reason why I'm pretty convinced it's not a
placebo effect is because I have these fucking weird dreams,
man.
They're like super potent dreams where a lot of times during them I'm aware that
I'm in a dream,
but the dream is so strong.
There's like no getting that on it.
It's like I'm always like,
well,
this is a dream,
right?
Yup.
This is just a dream.
Let's keep going.
Do you have ever have a lucid dream before?
I like this now.
I never had any,
like I've,
I've had moments,
but I've always in the middle of the moment freaked out and realize,
oh my God,
I am flying.
I'm controlling my fly.
This amazing.
Yeah.
But it felt so fucking real right before I woke up,
but I was only able to hold onto it.
Slippery for a few seconds.
Hmm.
Now since taking these fucking pills,
I hold onto it for like a half an hour sometimes and you do crazy shit.
Oh my God
talk.
Is that like the guy who like when you're playing grand theft auto,
when you get the baseball bat and just walk around and beat the shit out of
people,
you don't even play the game.
Mine was super bizarre and I've told the story.
So in the interest of brevity,
it was a werewolf and a gorilla were 69 in each other.
And my dream,
it was a big,
big fucking Brown Werewolf and a big gray gorilla and there were 69 each other
and I was trying to walk really quietly because I didn't want them to wake up
and I didn't want him to come after it.
It was so vivid.
It was the most ridiculous fucking vivid dream I've ever had.
I can remember the texture on the wall.
I could remember what the table looked like where there was 69 and each other,
I think worst turbo itching at the worst Joe Rogan during the other day.
And I was in it.
Yeah,
it was all about you.
And it was gang raped by a mummy.
No,
it was,
it was worse.
I did Alpha brain and,
and it was very creepy and I like almost don't even want to say it cause it was,
but I woke up and I told my girlfriend gay shit,
son,
I woke up and they will go time to devote to my European cues.
Sometimes it's best to keep you seeking support.
Yeah,
it does.
That mean.
All right.
So what happened is he had a fighter on you.
We're doing a podcast and we had to get a fighter on and then he like leaned
over and kissed you.
And I'm like,
well,
did that just happen?
And I'm like,
Joe,
the camera's on right now.
And he goes,
oh,
well,
I guess,
I guess there's nothing to say then or something like that.
You've like really intense and then the whole installs between them.
Then it was like a mitre too.
I think it was like GSP or something.
So weird.
Yeah.
You've got a very weird way or looking at men.
Brian.
I was creeped out by it.
Yeah,
me too.
I'm creeped out by the fact that you fucking thought that fucking Weirdo.
And then it was like the whole camera thing.
It was like you got really mad after the show about the camera being on and read
it.
Bring you ruined me.
I'm kissing.
Dude's about worried about you taking pictures of me.
Oh my goodness.
God.
Brian,
is this a regular flashlight or is this no,
no,
no.
Real slash flashlight.
John have,
Fran has the best flashlight,
flashlight joke.
He says we should make a fleshlight.
That's also a flashlight because you never know we flashlight is,
but you always know where your flashlight.
It is so true.
Right?
That's true.
Have fraud and you fucking genius.
You.
I have.